presumably when you're doing press for
this movie people are just everyone's
asking you if you've ever been on a
blind yeah so I will ask you have you
ever leave I went on a deaf date no I
didn't terrible do that please no I
haven't I have been married for ten
years so it's been long factors have
been out there but a lot of mice or
romantic assignation --zz we're at
parties and on areas of Wasteland you
know that you can't go on a blind date
unless it's in some very strange country
but that's the thing about a blind date
you don't know who you're gonna meet yes
you know when you see them it's aligned
once you make eye contact
[Laughter]
yes I guess as soon as you greet each
other yeah you can't that you cannot go
on a blender anymore and I think this is
probably the last film ever that will it
be about blind dates because now you can
you can look everybody up everyone has a
web presence and you can see if you if
you know you're gonna meet someone
you've met them on the net or you didn't
look at that thing where they're just
people it's a grinder what's Grindr
they'll be much happier I am married I'm
not gonna go and tinder or Grindr
did you ever do blind dates no oh I was
very unsuccessful with women you can
tell I get tense around women to leave
once she gave me a fiver she said it's
for a taxi I didn't know how to talk to
women this was my problem I didn't know
what I had to talk to when I was once
giving some advice
I kept sentiment friends who had women
they would women weren't next to my
friends a lot and I was like I want one
and they said just could be brave go and
shorten I said I don't know whatever
what know what to say and they said just
go and ask for a light you know for a
first it goes I really cannot to this
day I don't know why I did this
I don't smoke I didn't smoke at this
time and I went oh my I was so panicked
and so desperate to speak to a woman I
went over and I said if you got a light
and she came out her chamber yeah I've
got and just stood there like that light
my wife and I stopped her for several
years and now we're married
it is a happy ending I have the best
woman in the world hello darling
[Music]
dude I had a hack do in Spain and what's
the difference mean I had doing a stag
do
haggis camper can you be mates with Tom
Cruise or Rizzo in love you do fall in
love with him he's an amazing man